tous
les corses ont dit non mais syndicats de
corse-du-sud et de haute-corse rejette
les propositions du ministre de la
fonction publique la pollution en alaska
le commandant était sans doute vivre les
secours américains complètement désarmé
leur portage d'antenne 2 en alaska le
meurtre de liman de belgique a été
revendiquée il s'agit d'un groupe
clandestin pro iranien la revendication
est prise au sérieux
cent ans bon anniversaire madame c'est
aujourd'hui que la tour eiffel célèbre
son centenaire est encore jeune
bonsoir et avant de développer tous ces
titres la crise dans le football
français
tigana n'ira pas jouer à marseille la
ligue a mis son veto à ce transfert
provisoire
la ligue met ainsi un coup d'arrêt entre
à l'entente entre deux grands clubs
bordeaux et marseille qui se prêtait ces
derniers temps les joueurs avec une
certaine désinvolture
même si ces frais étaient légaux il est
certain qu'il faut c'est le championnat
de france puisque je vous le rappelle
darfeuille joue le titre de champion de
france aux girondins est à l'om ce soir
en pousse de hauts cris
dominique le glou gens ma mère le
magazine l'équipe de france les bleus
n'intéresse plus personne en revanche
les affaires du football intéresse
beaucoup de monde ce matin à la ligue
nationale ont statué sur le cas de gens
qui gagnent 1 qui lui pendant ce
temps-là s'entraînait bien
tranquillement sur la pelouse du stade
vélodrome pour l'olympique de marseille
et son président bernard tapie vu le
sourire de circonstance ne faisait aucun
doute la dérogation allait être accordée
à mr est désagréable surprise lorsque
jean sadoul le président de la ligue
refusait le prêt de jean tigana
on ne peut pas délibérément au fond
c'est le champion a déclaré nous ne
risquons rien sur le premier monter ni
descendre et dans ces commissions ont
favorisé le pigment cncd le meilleur
d'entre nous serait capitaine l'équipe
de france le capitaine légèrement
principal accusé bordeaux principales
victimes l'om l'om qui est donc parti à
metz sans son joker tiziana retournera à
bordeaux la ligue ayant décidé que le
prêt était de nature à fausser le
championnat
dans la mesure où bordeaux ayant déjà
bénéficié d'un renfort il y à un mois et
demi souvenez vous c'était eric cantona
il sembler paradoxal qu aujourd'hui la
même équipe bordeaux ce prix d'un de ses
meilleurs joueurs qui gagnent un
résultat bernard tapie a jusqu'à minuit
pour trouver un renfort qui ne viennent
pas d'un club ayant déjà bénéficié d'une
telle dérogation faut pas qu'ils soient
de bordeaux ça fait sur deux il faut
qu'ils plaisent à borg à borély car ça
m'a l'air d'être lui à la mode
maintenant apparemment il faut qu'ils en
fait il faut que ce soit un joueur qui
nous renforcent pas moi si j'ai bien
compris
alors d'ici minuit on a toutes les
chances de ne pas le trouver sur le
trouveront le fera ce mois là faire
n'est pas fini même si aujourd'hui la
ligue a retrouvé un peu de sa
crédibilité
la corse elle a donc dit non
l'intersyndicale des fonctionnaires de
haute-corse et de corse-du-sud refusent
les propositions du ministre de la
fonction publique
je vous rappelle qu'hier soir michel
durafour avait proposé aux grévistes qui
bloquent lille une indemnité de 2400
francs par an et par fonctionnaire plus
360 francs par enfant à charge
les corses ont donc répondu aujourd'hui
non l'explication dave mettez sur des
images qui ne sont pas toutes récentes
car aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas reçu
d'image de corse
fr3 corse est aussi en grève depuis
plusieurs semaines
ces jours derniers les grévistes avaient
accepté de diffuser les images et les
reportages de nos envoyés spéciaux
pas ce soir toute la journée à bastia le
suspense a duré
on attendait la réponse officielle du
syndicat aux propositions avancées hier
par michel durafour une indemnité de
transport de 2400 francs par an par
agent plus 360 francs par enfant à
charge
mais vers 17 heures après de longues
réunions de négociation avec le préfet
de haute-corse
la délégation a fait état du refus
catégorique des propositions du
gouvernement
le nom de bastia rejoignent et ainsi le
nom des grévistes d'ajaccio affirmer
haut et fort dès le matin à 200 francs
je reprends pas le boulot pour la nous
continuons lazio l'ultimatum du
gouvernement qui nous propose d'arrêter
l'action et de reprendre le travail
lundi matin a été rejeté de manière
extrêmement les syndicats se sont donné
rendez vous lundi matin 10 heures pour
une nouvelle assemblée générale
la corse entamera sa septième semaine de
grève
situation bloquée donc ce soir en corse
et jara leclerc cette semaine on a
l'impression de ne pas avoir avancé d'un
pouce et on y est encore une cartouche
de brûler pour le gouvernement après la
nomination d'un médiateur le rendez vous
manqué du week-end dernier et la
négociation introuvable avec michel
durafour l'ultime proposition sinon
l'ultimatum d'une indemnité de transport
de 2400 francs n'a pas permis de dénouer
le conflit
le début de dialogue engagé à bastia
tourné court
aucune rencontre n'est prévue pour le
week end qui sera dominé par l'entrée en
scène des nationalistes qui manifestent
de
alors retour à la case départ peut-être
pas complètement même si on le cache
parfois des nuances voire quelques
dissensions existent entre les syndicats
ainsi qu entre bastia et ajaccio la
lassitude après six semaines de grève et
la crainte de nouvelles violences et
dans certains fonctionnaires ne sont pas
hostiles au compromis quand d'autres
c'est vrai restent fermes sur leurs
revendications
les organisations vont mettre le
week-end à profit pour en débattre et l
consulteront lundi leur base dans chaque
administration
alors est ce la méthode coué le
gouvernement veut encore croire au
miracle de la réflexion agrémenté
éventuellement de quelques conseils
amicaux des élus et des syndicats
nationaux souvent mal à l'aise dans ce
conflit sinon il restera une dernière
cartouche la réunion dès que possible
des quatre tables rondes sur les
problèmes de l'économie et des
fonctionnaires corse dès que possible
c'est à dire au premier signe même
timide de retour à la nomma à la normale
que le gouvernement tels soran attend
maintenant depuis six semaines
merci gérard le double meurtre de
bruxelles il a donc été revendiquée
c'est un groupe clandestin pro iranien
qui affirme avoir tué l'imam de la
mosquée de bruxelles et son
bibliothécaire nous allons y revenir à
cette revendication mais tout de suite
voyons comment a évolué l'enquète sur ce
meurtre à bruxelles avec notre envoyé
spécial bruno gex il y à une heure que
la nouvelle est tombée
ils l'ont apprise pendant la prière
maintenant une sorte de la mosquée
certains sont excédés qu'est ce qu'ils
ont à faire avec nous ces gens-là nous a
rien à faire avec nous de quoi de quoi
s'occuper pour venir assassiné une
marche aimable est ce que c'est les
gendarmes du slam ou quoi
d'autres réagissent avec plus de recul
la violence est la dernière ressource
d'un missile utiliser la violence c'est
ce discriminés et se porter préjudice
est atteinte à toute la communauté
islamique
ainsi les les occidentaux vont réagir et
rebondir voilà comment sont tous les
musulmans intolérants intégristes
violent et agressif
donc il faut utiliser le dialogue
discuter on n'est pas d'accord mais on
ne voit pas frapper dessous du tout de
suite veulent s'accorder au moins sur un
point commun qui n'a rien à voir avec la
difficile là bas nous on a nos problèmes
ici on vit ici on veut être
on veut vivre en harmonie avec la
commune avec l'habile en belgique là
avec les belges avec nos amis avec c'est
pas possible on nous fait on nous pousse
à des problèmes qui se passe ailleurs
n'y en n'a rien à voir rien à voir rien
à voir l'appel au calme
c'était le voeu de l'imam pendant la
prière at il été exaucé il aura au moins
permis ce dialogue
le groupe terroriste qui a revendiqué
l'attentât s'intitule donc
l'organisation des soldats de la vérité
il détient en otage un médecin belge au
liban la revendication est prise au
sérieux
hervé boselli nous avons exécuté la
sentence de dieu affirme ce texte signé
les soldats de la vérité une
revendication dont la cible principale
et l'arabie saoudite
la famille royale y est menacée de
châtiment on l'accuse je cite de prôner
une politique israélienne
c'est de beyrouth que vient ce document
pour l'heure les enquêteurs semblent le
prendre au sérieux le groupe landes
clandestins de tendance pro iranienne
est connu c'est lui qui aurait été
enlevé au liban le médecin belge jan
cools ils travaillaient là bas pour une
organisation humanitaire norvégienne on
est sans nouvelles de lui
mais surtout les soldats de la vérité
sont très certainement le bras armé de
la vengeance dans une affaire qui
remonte à avril 88 à l'époque plusieurs
installations saoudienne avait subi une
série d'attentats
quatre suspects avaient été arrêtés et
exécutés depuis l'organisation des
soldats de la vérité venge c'est mort un
diplomate saoudien était assassiné à
bangkok un autre a failli l'être à
ankara la sphère belge pourrait être le
énième épisode de ce règlement le coq
les versets sataniques en étant que le
prétexte
mais attention ce n'est là
une hypothèse en toile de fond il y
aurait donc la question du leadership
sur le monde musulman
elle oppose l'iran al arabi seul vite au
milieu de ce bras de fer le contrôle des
lieux saints il y a deux ans la mecque
avait été le théâtre d'affrontements qui
avaient fait plus de 400 morts
la catastrophe de l'alaska à défaut de
trouver une solution pour stopper la
pollution on commence à comprendre les
causes de l'accident
le commandant du pétrolier le commandant
a dit woods le voit ci était bien ivre
au moment de l'accident
c'est le résultat d'une prise récent
mais ce résultat que la prise de sang
est déjà contestée en tout cas il
n'était pas sur la passerelle le
commandant pour diriger la navigation et
le lieutenant qui en avait la
responsabilité à ce moment là n'avait
pas les qualifications réglementer la
pollution elle s'étend d'heure en heure
la solidarité internationale commence à
jouer mais il est déjà bien tard
ainsi la société française elf à envoyer
du matériel et des experts même chose
pour une société norvégienne maintenant
au tour de valdez
on tente de nettoyer avec des moyens
souvent dérisoires l'échouage de l'exxon
valdez est la plus grande catastrophe
pétrolière de l'histoire des états unis
notre envoyé spécial jacquat bouchard
est en alaska
voici son reportage
la dernière ligne droite les ultimes
soubresauts un combat inégal pour cet
oiseau englué dans le magma visqueux qui
l'empêchent de prendre son envol
six jours après son accident le
pétrolier exxon valdez n'a pas fini
d'empoisonner la baie du prince william
un des joyaux de la côte sud de l'alaska
40 millions de litres de brut se sont
déversés dans ces eaux très
poissonneuses où viennent frayer les
bancs de harengs et les saumons depuis
naufrage de l'amoco cadiz au large du
littoral breton
jamais un mauvais coup d'une telle
ampleur n'avait été portée à
l'environnement marin dans l'ambiance
fiévreuse de son pc opérationnel
la compagnie exxon essaye de parer au
plus pressé après avoir clamé pendant
dix ans qu'une marée noire était à
exclure que toutes les précautions
étaient prises en cas de pépin or c'est
à la fois l'inertie et la panique qui
ont prévalu dès la formation de l'anah
poussé par le vent la nahb s'est déplacé
vers le sud de la baie du prince william
gars est il que vous apercevez derrière
moi elles ont été survolée en
hélicoptère il ya 48 heures par les
envoyés du président george bush
on leur avait annoncé qu'une véritable
armada de bateaux se trouvaient sur
place et déversé des produits pour
protéger les côtes
or les émissaires de washington n'ont
pas vu grand chose ils se sont étonnés
et ils ont posé des questions où sont
les bateaux on nous parle de nettoyage
mais où at il lieu
en réalité navires et barges de
nettoyage existe bien mais en nombre
très limité
au point que depuis six jours elles ont
recueilli seulement 1 % de la masse de
pétrole qui s'est répandu dans la baie
autant dire que les villages riverains
vivent dans l'angoissé le cas de fatigue
claque si fière de son église surmonté
de clocher à bulbe dans la tradition
russe
les 85 habitants sont convoqués
quotidiennement à des réunions
d'information au siège de la mairie
on y parle environnement et à venir de
la pêche la seule ressource locale
c'est la responsable communal doris
comme kraft une descendante de marins
bretons qui fait le point elle se plaint
notamment d'être tenues dans la plus
totale ignorance par la compagnie exxon
oui on en aura besoin d'un fake d'as à m
à nous ne savons pas ce qui va nous
arriver
inquiet bien entendu nous sommes
terriblement que vous pouvez l'imaginer
à bord de son bateau qui sillonnent la
baie depuis plus de 20 ans ralph
darbyshire était sceptique sur l'étendue
de la catastrophe
il a bien changé d'avis après une
tournée dans la zone sinistrée
je ne suis pas un spécialiste de
l'environnement mais je constate par
exemple que les lions de mer ne sont
plus là il est évident que les dégâts
seront énormes
quoi qu'il en soit après quelques jours
d'interdiction les pétroliers ont repris
leur chargement de brut au terminal de
l'oléoduc
pendant l'interruption l'alaska perdait
15 millions de francs de recettes
quotidiennes
malgré l'image accablant d'un oiseau
marin agonisant sur son rocher
il semble que la protection de la nature
et de la faune largement sacrifier aux
impératifs économiques de la star et
peut dire alors de cette malheureuse
otaries transformé en véritable caniche
par les plaques aggloméré de pétrole sur
son poids
et puis à propos de pollution toujours
et bien il faudra s'habituer à vivre
avec un conteneur de lin dan au fond de
la manche le lindane c'est un pesticides
hautement toxiques
il a coulé au large du cotentin à la
suite du naufrage d'un cargo panaméen
depuis le 15 mars on recherche ce
conteneur eh bien ces recherches seront
abandonnées la semaine prochaine il
reste maintenant à prier pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de fuite dans le conteneur la
politique qu'est la déclaration surprise
de charles pasqua ce matin à nice aux
journées parlementaires du rpr monsieur
pasqua a tenu un discours inattendu et
musclé il a pris carrément le
contre-pied du président du mouvement
jacques chirac sur le thème l'union à
droite ce n'est pas la panacée
pascal guimier au rpr une révolution
culturelle peut en cacher une autre
charles pasqua décidément et habile
politique débuts en douceur des journées
parlementaires
rien de bien croustillant dans le
programme officiel ce matin et puis
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur se
plante devant le micro discours imprévu
un pointu mais pas vraiment improvisé
premier coup de semonce les rénovateurs
dans le collimateur
je voudrais simplement que nous sachions
conduire cet aggiornamento
dans le souci qu'il en sorte un
mouvement gaulliste rénové certes
mouvement gaulliste nouveau sans doute
mais en tout cas un moment gaulliste le
poids des ans que j'ai été profondément
choqué par le vocabulaire qui fleurit
quelquefois en or en prenant garde aux
droits des monts et à la division
pour ma part j'aurais sans doute ne
saurait cautionner un processus qui
conduirait au morcellement puis à
l'éclatement en mouvement deuxième salve
haro sur l'union udf rpr charles pasqua
ferait la leçon à jacques chirac qu'il
ne s'y prendrait pas autrement
qu'avons nous pour tout programme
d'union pour tous les arts l'union pour
tout projet l'union
il faut nous débarrasser le jeu
chez l'union n'est pas la panacée
l'union et parle de faire un soin c'est
la victoire qui réduit des propos très
fermes mais dont le prudent monsieur
pasqua s'employer aussitôt à minimiser
la portée
non le gaulliste historique ne critique
pas la stratégie chirac
non le gardien du temple ne pense pas du
mal des jeunes rpr le rpr est donc bel
et bien nul à nîmes à vouloir l'union
enfin l'union pour les européennes il
fallait le dire au rpr on respire la
vedette du jour quant à elle n'a pas
perdu le sourire violents affrontements
ce matin à béziers entre petits
commerçants et forces de l'ordre à
l'origine l'incarcération de deux
d'entre eux qui avait eu maille à partir
avec un huissier les commerçants en
colère qui avaient fermé boutique
aujourd'hui s'en sont pris à un
supermarché maryse mano
c'est pour demander la mise en liberté
de deux commerçants de béziers que 500
adhérents du comité de défense des
commerçants et artisans ont semé la
pagaille dans les rues de la ville ce
matin un soutien musclé pour montagne à
quéven turine
ils sont en prison depuis six jours pour
avoir contesté l'huissier venu le
réclamer
en arriérés de cotisations sociales
devant le palais de justice
les échanges avec des forces de l'ordre
ont été vite vers midi tout était rentré
dans l'ordre
en apparence quand un petit groupe de
manifestants décident une opération
commando au magasin casino
seule restait ouvert pillage sa cage
ce n'est peut-être pas la fin de ce
mauvais film puisque le mouvement
appelle l nouvelle manifestation le 10
avril à sarcelles neuf familles vivaient
en caravane sur un terrain privé
et selon le mouvement atd quart monde
ces neuf familles ont été délogés par
des bulldozer aucune proposition de
relogement n'a été faite à la mairie de
sarcelles
pas de commentaire enquête emmanuel
tagne expulsé à coup de bulldozer neuf
familles vivaient là depuis plusieurs
années sur ce terrain privé des familles
nombreuses avec souvent plus de quatre
enfants tous scolarisés dans les écoles
de sarcelles la vie dans des caravanes
vétuste au milieu des immondices et des
rats aucun autre endroit où s'installer
en banlieue parisienne tous les terrains
pour nomades sont saturés tout récemment
les voisins se plaignent de
l'insalubrité du lieu plainte transmise
à la mairie puis à la préfecture qui
prend un arrêté d'expulsion malgré les
démarches des familles les bulldozer
sont entrés en action mercredi matin
prost un problème qui est fait
significatif dans la mesure où
maintenant on voit de plus en plus dans
le pourtour des grandes villes des
familles qui sont obligés de vivre en
caravane parce qu'elles sont trop démuni
pour pouvoir habiter dans les hlm et
qu'on repousse partout parce que
personne ne veut d'elle et ce qu'il faut
c'est que ces familles on les considère
comme des familles avec des enfants
comme nous et qu'on voit qu'elles ont
comme nous envie d'une stabilité pour
que leurs enfants puissent sortir de la
misère et des difficultés depuis trois
jours quarante personnes parcourent donc
les routes du val d'oise en quête d'un
lieu où vivre les enfants ne sont plus
scolarisés c'est l'errance de terrain
vague en parking d'où ils sont toujours
refoulés dans le val d'oise déjà
vingt-cinq mille demandes de logements
prioritaires mais chaque année on ne
peut re logés en hlm que 2000 familles
et puisque nous parlons de sarcelles et
bien cette information sans aucun
rapport aux allées le voir les
politiques cette fois l'élection
municipale dans cette ville est contesté
deux candidats de gauche dont le
socialiste dominique strauss kahn
viennent en effet de déposer un recours
en annulation
événement ce soir apostrophe sur antenne
2 bien sûr bernard pivot reçoit le
premier ministre espagnol felipe
gonzalez fans homme de culture qui
parlera avec passion de ses lectures il
sera accompagné de plusieurs écrivains
espagnols
c'est vrai monsieur gonzalez est un
grand consommateur d'oeuvres littéraires
le premier ministre espagnol a passé la
journée à paris et bien sûr il a
rencontré le président mitterrand vaste
tour d'horizon entre les deux hommes
avec en toile de fond une très grosse
partie qui se joue à propos de l' eta
l'organisation indépendantiste basque en
ce moment même il faut le savoir
des négociations ont lieu en algérie
entre le gouvernement espagnol et le thé
à négociations difficiles qui entraîne
en ce moment une guerre de communiqués
explications dominique tiers de quoi
peuvent-ils bien se parler
la caméra tourne mais les micros sont
trop loin de littérature peut-être plus
certainement de politique de l'europe
mais aussi de l'un des problèmes majeurs
qui se posent aujourd'hui au
gouvernement espagnol
la violence cette violence qui a fait
plus de 500 morts en dix ans celle qui
pourrait reprendre en espagne si les
négociations entre madrid et le groupe
indépendantiste basque eta était
définitivement rompu c'est à alger que
tout se joue alger où l'on discute des
conditions du rétablissement illimité de
la paix civile à la tête de la
délégation de thé à fonctionner de shv
est une délégation qui selon un
communiqué il y à quatre jours du groupe
séparatiste devrait s'étoffer s'agrandir
eta réclament la présence à la table des
négociations de trois autres militants
arrêtés et détenus en france
parmi eux yushu ternira considéré par
les policiers espagnols comme le numéro
un de tes airs militaires
difficile d'imaginer que cette question
n'est pas été évoqué entre le chef du
gouvernement espagnol et le premier
ministre français mais à sa sortie de
matignon
philippe even vallès est resté très
discret et pourra faire des décorateurs
fait cet essai test m
ça chauffe un pétage obscur suspense et
inquiétude à madrid où le porte parole
du gouvernement reconnaît publiquement
que la situation est extrêmement
délicate situation encore plus complexe
depuis le nouvel ultimatum de théa
militaire ota donne 72 heures au
gouvernement espagnol pour rectifier ce
communiqué paru mardi
derrière une guerre des mots sans doute
une revendication essentielle le terrain
militaire que le résultat des
négociations d'alger soit soumis par
référendum aux peuple basque des basques
qui étaient descendus dans la rues par
dizaines de milliers pour réclamer la
paix à présent le temps compte les deux
parties ont 72 heures pour peut-être
prendre le chemin de l'art muscu
jugement aux assises de paris de quatre
terroristes du gal il s'agit de ce
groupe qui lutte contre le mouvement
séparatiste basque eta
trois de ces inculpés du galon été
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle le quatrième a été acquitté
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
internationales à commencer par les
aveux du premier ministre japonais
oui il a touché des pots de vin c'est le
fameux scandale recruit éric perrin le
premier ministre japonais noboru
takeshita avoue avoir couché
l'équivalent de 900 mille francs de la
société recruit ce scandale politique et
financier secoue tout le gouvernement
poussé dans ses derniers retranchements
le premier ministre a dû se résigner à
cette hara-kiri politique
sa popularité est tombée à 9 % d'avis
favorables
l'opposition demande la démission du
cabinet et l'organisation d'élections
anticipées
échanges de 17 prisonniers de guerre à
la frontière entre l'angola et la
namibie
demain matin un cessez le feu doit
officiellement entrer en vigueur entre
les forces sud africaine qui contrôle le
territoire depuis 75 ans et les
combattants du swap au principal
mouvement nationaliste comme le prévoit
la résolution 435
les nations unies vont désormais
superviser la situation jusqu'à
l'élection en novembre prochain d'une
assemblée constituante
cette élection devait être l'ultime
étape de l'indépendance de la namibie
accord entre la france et le canada dans
le conflit sur la pêche
après trois ans de négociations les deux
pays ont finalement définit les quotas
français au large de saint pierre et
miquelon et dans les eaux canadiennes de
l'atlantique la fin de la guerre de la
morue est un bon point dans les
relations entre les deux états mais
c'est accor globalement favorables au
canada pourrait raviver les différends
entre saint pierre et miquelon et la
métropole
le monde scientifique en ébullition la
semaine dernière deux savants de salt
lake city ont annoncé qu'il était
possible de réaliser une fusion
thermonucléaire à froid est bien une
semaine après un troisième chercheurs de
la même université affirme être parvenu
aux mêmes résultats
si elles se vérifient cette découverte
est capitale car elle permettrait
d'obtenir de nrj avec un matériel
extrêmement fins yves dumez vous prenez
un flacon comme celui-ci rempli
d'hydrogène lourds ou deutérium et vous
y plonger deux électrodes en platine et
en palladium
ensuite comme pour une électrolyse et
sous l'action d'un fort courant
électrique les noyaux de deutérium vont
se concentrer sur une des électrodes et
fusionner entre eux martin fleischman et
stanley pons affirme ainsi avoir obtenu
un dégagement de chaleur de 1500 degrés
pendant une centaine d'heures cela
signifie qu'il aurait réussi à maîtriser
la fusion thermonucléaire à froid et
avec un matériel rudimentaire pendant
que les physiciens du monde entier
cherchent à obtenir le même résultat
mise avec d'énormes machines alors au
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
on est tout de même un peu sceptique
autrefois dans le passé on a su faire
des étincelles en frottant de silex mais
avec ça on ne savait pas chauffer une
maison pour être juste allumer du feu
après quand on a su construire au foyer
aujourd'hui haïti réactions
thermonucléaires on en est au stade de
l'étincelle est ce qu'on pu faire ces
gens c'est probablement encore une fois
des étincelles
les pirisiens pensais qu'il fallait pour
maintenir ce feu nucléaire
une température d'environ 100 millions
de degrés alors réaliser cette fusion à
froid
ce serait une véritable révolution où
l'homme maîtriserait l'énergie du soleil
bonne anniversaire madame il est
d'autant plus facile de vous souhaiter
que vous habitez à deux pas de nous
madame est une alerte centenaire qui a
fêté aujourd'hui 31 mars son siècle
c'est la tour eiffel ce que vous ne
savez peut-être pas tous c'est qu'elle
avait été construite elle aussi pour
célébrer un centenaire celui de la
révolution patrick esther à la fin du
siècle dernier
les idées de construction pour une tour
de 1000 pieds plane sur les villes de
londres philadelphie chicago mais la
première étude sérieuse bien sûr sera
française elle est signée de la main de
l'ingénieur coquelin en 1884 maurice
coquelin était employé par la société fl
au début son patron du style eiffel
ne croyez pas ce projet mais il eu
l'intelligence de laisser travailler
coquelin puis il déposa un brevet en
commun avec lui dans l'imagination
fertile de messieurs nougué et sauve est
architecte
le projet ce permis quelques détours
audacieux mais finalement le sérieux des
techniciens l'emporta les dix-huit mille
pièces qui composent la tour furent
minutieusement dessiner puis usines et
dans les ateliers de levallois-perret
avant d'être transportée sur le champ de
mars
en 1887 tandis que l'ouvragé
préfabriqués monte en un temps record
eiffel indemnisera généreusement son
ingénieur et donnera tout naturellement
son propre nom à la tour
200 ouvriers 800000 river 25 mois de
travail aucun accident mortel un exploit
humain un exploit industriels un exploit
financiers pour payer les travaux
gustave eiffel avait investi sa fortune
personnelle mais lorsque le canon tonna
pour saluer le dernier soir de
l'exposition universelle du savs avait
déjà remboursé totalement la
construction de sa tour en faisant payer
2 francs chaque visiteur cela dit les
meilleures affaires financières furent
quand même réalisé par les quatre
escrocs britanniques et allemands qui à
quatre reprises en un siècle vendirent
la tour eiffel à des ferrailleurs à
raison de 2 francs le kilo pour dix
mille cent tonnes
vous pouvez leur tirez votre chapeau
monsieur hessel que ce sont moins
fatigués que vous pour faire fortune
dans un mois et demi c'est le festival
de cannes l'événement mondial du cinéma
antenne 2 bien sûr vous le fera vivre
pour annoncer ce festival une affiche
c'est bien normal son créateur est un
jeune homme de 21 ans comme quoi on ne
fait pas toujours appel aux valeurs
consacrées dans le domaine de la pub
en exclusivité voici la fiche du
festival de cannes jean-claude d'arrigo
la fiche du 42e festival de cannes où la
découvrons en même temps que l'auteur et
son modèle prénommé marianne cela ne
s'invente pas le vrai classique un brin
aguicheuse très dessinée est à première
vue un peu cocardières c'est avant tout
une affiche cinéma bon écoute et curieux
cinéphiles
on sent l'oriflamme c'est avant tout une
véhicule de série de villes sur lequel
on voit d'ailleurs une audience au
centenaire de la naissance d'amérique
ans enfin il aurait eu 100 ans cette
année est bon la déchirure le côté le
trompe l'oeil
pardon cinéma ce qui la religion pour
moi
le festival de cannes est avant tout le
rendez vous mondial du cinéma de toutes
les cinématographies mais on ne pouvait
pas bien évidemment ne pas faire un ou
deux clins d'yeux au bicentenaire de la
révolution française alors il y en aura
deux dont l'un sera annoncée le 19 avril
lors de la conférence de presse de
l'annonce des films tous les événements
du festival et le second est bien celle
affiche qui va faire le tour du monde
les pronostics du tiers c'est pour
demain il se court à vincennes alors
voici ce que nous propose pierrette brès
si vous voulez jouer écouter pire est le
15 le 18 le dise le 13 le 8 le 17 le 6
et le cas tout de suite la météo ce sera
laurent cabrol qui se fait des cheveux
parce que le temps se gâte un petit peu
et ce n'est pas un poisson d'avril
la dernière édition en régnier vers 23
heures aussitôt après apostrophe pour le
week-end comme d'habitude l'informateur
seront daniel bilalian philippe gassot
et betty dureau et lundi en fait même
lieu et place vous retrouverez christine
ockrent excellente soirée sur antenne 2